komm schon du schaffst es ja ich bin
eine fledermaus
hallöchen liebe freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft electric auf gebieten
zusammen immer noch mit max es nacht und
es sind regie und paletten drauf also
rief ich wohl noch eine weitere folge
auf yahoo als dach so ein bisschen erde
damit ich mal ganz kurzem eine scheiß
wand da hochkommen oder komm ich mache
das jetzt eben ich mache jetzt eben ganz
viele leitern und mach mir seine treppe
hoch lkw war daniel wießler
runtergegangen verbluten auch also die
werden wahrscheinlich zusammen hoffen
aber natürlich wundert ein drache hat
sich natürlich noch nicht wiedergefunden
wir nehmen es gerade direkt im anschluss
auf und deshalb wieder gibt es ja keine
allzu große hoffnung dass das er jetzt
gerade wieder da ist es seinen also
irgendwie weg gibt backt oder sowas
luca wenn du eine spinne die stan seiten
getötet die für mich brauche
spinnenfäden damit ich mir dann eine
angegriffen kann und dann später für
meinen drachen die sachen zu angeln also
die fische man muss hier mit kartnig
habe gerade leiter gesetzen daran
einfach keine von diesen komischen
teilen dazwischen bei sonderleiter am
thema montierten nicht mehr bei den
teams aus der bund also was er ist in
meiner nähe ich habe noch kein richtiges
aber der winter ganz in der nähe wo ich
mich die ersten folgen rumgetrieben habe
so ich wollte jetzt mal in die andere
richtung fliegen
das quantum das ist irgendwie cool luca
komm her kommen dass dessen fledermaus
in einer schlucht wo in welcher schlucht
die direkt bei deinem haus ist oder weil
ich doch gerade da komme ich doch kommen
wieder ich behalte im auge die
fledermaus dem es jetzt schaffen dass du
eine fledermaus kriegsmann ok cool war
ich fertig war kleid mich eben als
einschicken
der ist genau liest du siehst du wo ich
bin
ich leg mich in die lage dudelsack nee
ich sehe nicht wo du bist aber ich komme
ich zu dir ja also unten in der hitze in
dieser schlucht da wo wir am anfang war
im auge die fledermaus designer irgendwo
ruhig bleiben
ich glaube die sind nie reine die
viecher du bist so ich kann ich schon
mal runter zocken magst du wirst du
entweder unter mir in meiner schlucht wo
ich die ganzen folgen schon verbreitet
ich sehe zwei fledermäuse ja ich bin
nicht die falsche ich habe jetzt auch
ein halbes herz gezeigt also ein schlag
musst du dir geben welcher dann wieder
vor den fliegt die vorne fliegt die
vorne blickt die hier komm schon
wo ist sie denn er hat ich verwahre mich
erstmal zurück hier ist fallout
irgendwie werde der wasserfall geschafft
die größten wasserfall alter als ob das
der wasserfall ist desolat ist ja ich
höre du kriegst du willst bleib stehen
federer
die flick ball hoch wie vielleicht
kriegen die pause du siehst dies
wiederholt das ist wieder runter hier
bahnen
ja ich bin ich bin unseren box komm
schon ist es jedem wasserfall
ich weiß nicht wer du bist diesmal
zurück dies jetzt hier direkt bei mir
hoffe schon
ich wäre fast gestorben alter wie soll
denn ein komisches loch runtergefallen
bin meine medien skipper hat die auch
noch machen
komm schon du schaffst es ja ich bin mal
weg von diesem scheiß wasserfall der wir
haben es geschafft du bist mit
fledermaus ich fliege mal weg joha vidal
danke klar ist dass er dauernd sind
jetzt auch spinnen ich glaube ich könnte
jetzt eine spinne hier war mein drach
wenn man nicht weg wenn ich eine spinne
töte heißt es dass ich dann wände
hochklettern kann ja genau aber du hast
jetzt hoch fliegen von daher probleme
erklären auch ich bin aber luca fliegt
jetzt auch mal in eine richtung das um
nachzusehen ob da irgendwo ob er
irgendwo zeug ist was wir brauchen
ich kann mich nicht zurück verwandeln
der holt trugen
ich will jetzt eine coole fledermaus ja
ich würde gerne erstmal dass wir
schlafen schlafen gehen ich kann nicht
schlafen weniger komplett was man ja
klar hält als disc on point
dadurch kann man darf nicht nur server
oder du kannst aber an unserer
hauptgebäude gehen dabei foxtrott das
unglaublich betten
ich denke ich dass nein das ist ja
tagsüber ist ein bisschen vorteilhafter
da hast du schon recht ruhig weg mal in
so hoffen die konkreter verwandlung dann
mache ich mir kurz aus dem eisen was ich
hier habe neue sachen die ich brauche
wie hallo hallo was machst du hier aus
eine spitzhacke eine axt und einer
schärfe des das starthaus sieht echt
schön aus so dessen krieg beim start aus
[ __ ] es explodiert
da ist noch einer dass nach einer dumm
ich bin ich mache mir einfach zwei arien
jazz place on
start ups in die luft gejagt wie sie ist
auch der rheinländer creeper drin sind
du hast gesagt die sache schlafen ja
aber du kannst ob der körper drin sind
oder nicht kommt noch ein alter mann
du bist voll leise gerade ich bin ja
jetzt bist du leute ein bisschen weit
weg von einem mikrofon war
ich habe jetzt auch einen tollen helm
bestimmt voll unnötig dass migration
riesige christus machte kam ein jugend
zu schlafen als ob da keine betten darin
sind ja keine wetten
du hast mich betrogen eigentlich waren
da einmal betten
ich glaube kein wort ich habe eigentlich
schon alles erkundet nur in münchen im
geldliche richtung habe ich bin noch
nicht geflogen
ja ich glaub ich fliege jetzt auch mal
ein bisschen nicht mit ein bisschen
frieden mit ja auf jeden fall macht ist
ich habe jetzt meinen frieden bei mir in
der belastung mit dem wird nun so war
das knapp ich habe gedacht ich eine
fledermaus und springen einfach aus
meinem haus runter weiße ich war keine
fledermaus ich war ich aber dann zum
glück zum glück war der wasser ich bin
einfach in das wasser gesprungen war
junge ich mir einfach gestorben
die gehören übermut mein gott wie kann
ich mir ich hab waypoint so rothe der
jahn ach so ja okay die werden immer
angezeigt die dann immer angezeigt also
eigentlich so lang keine neue gruppe
erstellt bei dem klub nur die neue
gruppe erstellt ich hab's auch noch
nicht so ganz ruhig blickt aber ich
finde es einfach immer noch krass dass
jemand den weg genommen hat ich weiß
irgendwie echt im moment nicht so was
ich machen soll
oha alter jetzt entdecke ich aber auch
sachen wenn man rumfliegen kann oder
skelett das ist einfach so traurig ich
gucke immer wieder nach ob er noch da
ist meinte aber es ist einfach ich denke
mal das ist ein schlechter traum wahr
aber es ist einfach wahr
es ist ein trauerspiel manchmal sind es
ist echt schrecklich mann ich wäre auch
in irgendeine richtung aber ich finde
keine ich finde auch meine dürfte man
das ist so doof hab ich halt ein anderes
bio mit so charakteren gibt es alles
cool so blüten und so rot-gelben bäumen
aber können es nicht vorwerfen dass wir
nicht den vordersten
produktiv zu sein weil wir suchen ja die
ganze zeit nach nach diesen dingen aber
die sind nicht da ich habe
herausgefunden
wir brauchen eigentlich nur eine katze
oder ist das gerät mit dem komischen
bogen ingenieurs weiß nicht porös
riesiger baum schon richtig riesiger
baum mit zu 4 stimmen als grundlage also
einfach mal gesehen aber hier ist kann
ich den wir mitnehmen
du kannst den baum mitnehmen nee also
dass ich den e fälle
vielleicht kriegen seines lieblings
kriegskasse dass wir euch machen
aber du musst in anhalt einzelnen fällen
dann hast du als einhalten so was aber
als ganzen mitnehmen wir nicht diesen
diesem motto der alle bäume auf einmal
ab dezember
der genaue termin steht aber schon geil
aus leute sondern ein riesiger baum wer
schon schuldig vor allem hier so eine
richtig coole bucht auch baum liebst du
dich hier wohnen
wir sind so weit weg von der stadt oder
bist du nicht so weit weg sondern so
eine kleine bucht er doch ich bin schon
relativ weit weg aber sieht wunderschön
hier aus muss man ganz kurz sagen es ist
echt schön
ich bin ja noch auf der suche nach und
diese riesigen bäume sind echt und turn
und weiß ich dass biom gefällt mir
irgendwie dass das ist auch echt wären
also bei mir sind auch ein paar große
bäume ich war ich habe auch noch gar
nicht darüber nachgedacht wo ich mich
denn hin bauer weil das war weniger
meinung ist gehen wir jetzt um so meinen
drachen und sowas in den ersten folgen
aber dadurch dass er jetzt irgendwie weg
ist warum auch immer musste ich mich
jetzt irgendwie anders orientieren
also ich hatte mich um dinge kümmern
dass ihm jetzt zum beispiel ein paar
fische fangen kann aber ich mache das
einfach mal ich meine ich bin jetzt
schon in drei richtungen geflogen
ich habe noch keine keine bücher dazu
eine gesehen ich fliege auch überall hin
ich sehe alles möglich außer wüstenluft
dadurch dass so viele wie oh mann da
sind ist einfach so was er so etwas
grundlegendes wie eine wüste nicht mehr
da aber kann man die map nicht irgendwie
ganz groß machen dass man sieht wo
wüsten sind wo wüsten verhindert dass du
die ganze dass du die maps ist die ganze
irgendwie wenn man auf einem drückt oder
so sieht man das ja und dass man einfach
gucken kann mit wüsten sind und sonst
auf
das auf m kann man das machen aber dann
halt da sind halt nur die teile sichtbar
die du dir selbst schon erkundet hast
ich nehme es erstmal alles mit was sich
so hier einen ort sehe meine freunde
gemacht
da kann man nichts falsch machen so
ressentiment bin ich drin da muss jetzt
mal gucken wie greift man sich dennoch
meine angel das liegt aber echt gemein
er das echt scheiße bei mir geht es im
moment das bei mir geht's auch wenn ich
im flieger aber wenn ich in erz abbauen
dann kommen die teilweise wieder zurück
und soll das ist echt nicht sogar sehr
sehr komisch
ich nehme es einfach mal alles mit
silver gold alles schreibt mir am besten
meine kommentare was davon sinnvoll ist
weil ich möchte ja nicht so viel so
kräften sondern mehr so entdecken und
ich nehme es erstmal die grundsache mit
weil nicht dass nachher wieder so wie
bei hero so alles möglich weg ist da
findest du dann gar keinen gar keine
dings mehr gar nicht diese pflanzen
diese rüstung machen kannst und es gibt
ja hier sogar in diesem motto keine
himmels welt ein himmels welt gibt es
auch in welche coolen rüstungen aus der
e mails welt nur in dieser welt gibt es
eine erste stellt das heißt irgendwie ms
dynamics oder sowas kanal ob es richtig
aussprechen
und das ist das stärkste überhaupt aber
wirklich mit abstand das stärkste
wie kommt man diese himmels welt das
weiß ich nicht ganz genau auf jeden fall
ist relativ kompliziert wir könnten
allerdings wenn du bock hast könnten wir
in die trophy kraft welt gehen keine
kohle items doch da kannst du dir
kokosnuss granaten holen ok kohl aber
ich am liebsten wirklich irgendwie so
ein richtig richtig cool umrüstung wohl
nichts passieren kann weil das wichtig
für mich in asow in der drop kraft ist
in der trafik ref welt gibt es eine
rüste eine rüstung also ich mich nicht
nur so eine doofe die rüstung sondern
irgendwie sowas die was kann als er in
der tat gibt es in der rüstung da
kriegst du gar keinen schaden sondern es
geht irgendwie auch deine hunger keulen
oder so ok ja und ich kann hier einfach
und angel gerade hey ich werde manchmal
verrückte jeden fall wünschen wieder bei
11 30 sind und ich will den rückweg
locker noch ein paar minuten brauche
mehr stimmt der du bist ganz still
weggeflogen war bei mir auch sein
letzter wir haben einfach keine kakteen
gefunden man so ein mist hey schaut mal
eben was hier noch gibt alles
es ist einfach so ärgerlich ich könnte
jetzt meinen drachen züchte ich hab's
gold wertvoll für irgendwelche kräftigen
sachen gold ich glaube es gab ja auch
diese diese gold karl cables aber weil
ich ja oder du hast du damals abgespielt
wird ja aber das ist das hier drin gibt
ich muss gar nicht dachte das wäre und
komplett anders aber das ist so viele
ausgleichskasse ich glaube dieser eine
dieser sehr technik basiert ist ist
bisher sehr ähnlich computer kraft
wahrscheinlich und dies mit dem computer
kraft nicht computer kravanja diese
turtles und so was willst du willst und
die ganzen die atmosphäre passen aber
generell ist schon sehr sehr viel
ähnlich komm schon fischproben bei sun
fisch alter da oben sind so krass viele
wurden weite teile die in der luft
schweben als es das sind das sind
spezielle macht glaube ich wenn mich
nicht alles täuscht
nee das ist sind so wollten mäßig okay
kann ich darauf laufen neda fliege ich
durch das cloud
ach so ja viel kannst du es abbauen doch
kann ich kannst du uns mitnehmen
ja wie chili hatte dann klaut highlight
in flushing save you when you for your
perfect dann kannst du dir unten an dein
haus kannst du dir so eine kleine so
einem kleinen becken sag ich mal mit
diesem cloud stone sag ich mal machen
und dann kannst du einmal rein springen
aber das brauche ich damit nichts
schneller ab doch coatings dabei werden
die fledermaus bin ist ja auch egal
eigentlich schon aber wenn du irgendwann
keine fehler machst wirst du sterben
wenn du es nicht hättest ich bin cool
ich habe auch über die blitz ist aber
überall
ich bin echt geschlechter online
minecraft wir möchten hier rum
alle hangeln hotel dass es regnet gerade
die gerade durch diese überaus dich
wachsende welt und alles ist irgendwie
cool
er ist auf jeden fall sehr lange
schlucht so mittendrin
ich glaube spende hier meine folge jetzt
einfach solch ein paar schafe für dich
töten
ein scharfer super das war echt mega die
turniere die auch endlich schlafen kann
aber immer so eklig hasse das wenn
schafe so im dschungel sind ergibt sich
dann unsere grenzen blätter oder aber
bei allen tieren ist das so die nur
einen block hoch sind also auch bei mir
kam aus goma schweine wirklich was zu
festigen fräsen
ich bin hier bauen schwein man also ich
hab jetzt auf jeden fall genug genug
fische ich werde mich darum kümmern dass
ich in der nächsten folge meinen drachen
wieder kriege und die oder nicht ist
alles unproblematisch würde ich sagen
bei mir auch ich würde sagen wir beenden
die folge jetzt mal ich beende das
einfach hier auf meinem coolen
großenbaum und dann gehe ich mal runter
und ich gucke in die richtung die ich
nicht mal hin fliegen muss ich sagen es
euch gefallen hat und ich ein bisschen
der kunde habt und euch gefiel das
anlasses zeigt es mit einer bewertung
ich hoffe bei max vorbei und sehen uns
morgen in angst ein paar wieder ciao